Hey Wisecrack! Jared here.
And today we're talking about the
happiest show in the Netflix's catalogue
BoJack Horseman.
With its colorful animation, talking animals, and Hollywood glamour
BoJack might look like your
typical happy-go-lucky cartoon
but this is far from the case.
The show’s light hearted veneer hides a dark
and downright depressing reality
which is fitting given its focus on the disillusionment
that inevitably comes
when you look beneath the surface.
BoJack reveals the ugly, narcissistic reality that lies behind the dazzling façade of Hollywoo.
BoJack: "Most important thing is you gotta give the people what they want."
"Even if it KILLS you."
"Even if it empties you out until there's
nothing left to empty."
From Mr. Peanutbutter's feigned interest
"I wanna talk to you..."
"...ERICKA!"
to studio executives only focused on money
to meaningless award ceremonies that only
reward those with established names.
In other words:
Charlotte: “Hollywoo’s a real pretty town that’s"
"smack on top of all that black tar."
"By the time you realize you’re sinking"
"it’s too late.”
But the show goes far deeper.
Hollywoo could be considered a metaphor for
existence in general.
Just like the façade of Hollywoo covers up the reality
of an ugly, hollow industry
the trappings of our daily lives cover up the
meaninglessness of existence itself.
This idea, known as
“Existential Nihilism”
is foundational to “BoJack Horseman.”
If life is truly meaningless then how are we supposed to deal with it?
Welcome to this Wisecrack Edition on: The philosophy of “BoJack Horseman.”
What does it know? Does it know things? Let's find out!
But before we dive in
This Wisecrack edition is sponsored by
Best Fiends
and the newest game in the Best Fiends trilogy:
Best Fiends Forever
It's the same characters and story as before
but a totally different kind of game.
An addictive clicker adventure where you
slap, collect, and level up pretty much everything
while trying to get as far as you can as fast as you can.
Also, something we really like
in edition to making crazy addicting games like this
Best fiends gives back.
As a supporter of the charity Oceana.
Helping protect the worlds oceans.
So be sure to check out the new Best Fiends game.
It's FREE and you can download it from the link below.
Let us know how far you get
and thanks again to Best Fiends
for sponsoring this video.
Part 1: Distract yourself
A key way to cope with the anguish
of a meaningless world
is to simply distract yourself.
Naomi Watts: "I just wanted to do something
light and fun"
"to distract me from the deep well of sadness that is my life."
Princess Carolyn persistently distracts
herself with her job
and her compulsive need to
fix the life of those she cares about.
Despite complaining about work dominating her life
she can’t actually handle the free time
that comes without it.
Lora: "Are you gonna head out soon?"
Princess Carolyn: "Where else would I go?"
When her agency folds
she finally has time for the relationship
she always wanted
but still finds a way to get right back to the
Hollywoo grindstone.
Princess Carolyn: "I think I'm having an epiphany."
"I'M GONNA BE A MANAGER!"
Ralph: "Oohh.."
Todd, BoJack’s best friend and perpetual mooch is happy as long as he has something to do
Todd: "Hooray! A task!"
The one time we do see Todd without anything to do
he immediately starts to spiral into existential despair.
Todd: "I need something to do."
"A job or a task or a direction in life."
"Do I have a purpose?"
before finding Something to take his mind off it.
Todd may not have much direction or common sense
but he manages to keep himself busy:
He composes a space opera
builds his own Disneyland
and starts a number of businesses.
"An all hallow's eve store..."
"...in January?"
"How fiendishly droll."
"Nuhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
*crash*
Similarly, Mr. Peanutbutter spends his life
in a state of distraction.
Though he may seem like a moron
BoJack: "He's so stupid, he doesn't realize how miserable he should be."
Mr. Peanutbutter is more self aware than most.
Mr. Peanutbutter: "The universe is a cruel uncaring void."
"The key to being happy isn't the search for meaning."
"It's to just keep yourself busy
with unimportant nonsense."
"And eventually..."
"...you'll be dead."
And then there’s BoJack.
BoJack’s whole life is a series of distractions.
The way BoJack spends his days is so trivial
that the show often makes a joke of not showing us
what he’s doing half the time.
BoJack: "Yeaaah!"
"Two days!"
"I can do all those things."
*two days later*
BoJack: "Oh shit!"
"I didn't do any of those things."
In fact, in the years since "Horsin' Around"
BoJack has been able to drift through life
in a near constant state of distraction.
Princess Carolyn: "Horsin' Around?"
"That ended 11 years ago."
BoJack: "Really?"
"Where does the time go?"
*drinks to forget*
But in the first episode
BoJack has a “mild anxiety attack” that
sends him to the hospital.
The doctor tells him he needs to
take it easier.
Princess Carolyn: "Take it easy!? Are you kidding?"
"He doesn't have a job he has no real responsibilities he doesn't do anything but take it easy."
The show asks a question commonly directed
at celebrities
They have everything, so how could they not be happy?
BoJack: "Great house, great career, 'great life' "
"That must be why I'm so goddamn happy all the time."
This question was addressed by 17th Century philosopher Blaise Pascal
who is considered by many to be a
precursor to the Existentialists.
For Pascal, when given too much time to think
humans will eventually contemplate
their own insignificance
which inevitably bums them out.
Or as Pascal puts it:
“I have discovered that all the unhappiness
of men arises from one single fact:
that they cannot stay quietly in their own chamber.
I have found that there is one very real reason
namely, the natural poverty of our feeble
and mortal condition
so miserable that nothing
can comfort us when we think of it closely.”
For Pascal, humans have a natural psychological
defense mechanism
that keeps these thoughts at bay:
We’re really easily distracted.
And when we’re distracted we stop thinking about our existence
and can be, if not happy at least functional.
Pascal directly addressed the
unhappy celebrity question
though he uses kings instead of movie stars:
“Yet, when we imagine a king attended with
every pleasure he can feel
if he be without diversion and be left to consider
and reflect on what he is
this feeble happiness will not sustain him.”
Like a king
BoJack has no serious struggle to occupy his life.
Instead, he has to spend all of his time trying
to distract himself
so that he never has to think about the
reality of his situation.
Although he succeeds in doing this for years
the whole charade comes crashing down
when he reads Diane’s book
“One Trick Pony.”
In the book, BoJack sees an honest reflection of himself
warts and all.
He is forced to face all the things he really is and isn’t
and to confront the extent of his self-deception.
"I love the part about how you became famous."
"You could be constantly surrounded by distraction"
"and wouldn't have to be alone with yourself."
So what should BoJack do
now that his distraction has crumbled?
For Pascal, once you’ve passed the critical point where diversion will no longer sustain you
the only recourse is to turn to God.
But for BoJack this isn’t an option.
It seems that Hollywoo is a post-God-Is-Dead world.
In the Christmas Special, the show uses Santa Claus
as a stand-in
to discuss the non-existence of God:
BoJack: “He’s a lie that grown ups made up because"
"we like to believe that there’s an order to the universe"
"and that good behavior will lead to happiness"
"but the fact is"
"that just isn’t true.”
But if there’s no God
where are we supposed to turn?
For BoJack, the first choice is
right back to distraction.
The show provides two separate
case studies
of what happens when you try to force distraction
after the illusion has been broken
and neither ends well.
First, Secretariat gives a young BoJack advice
that basically amounts to
“Don’t Think About It.”
*same as Rick Sanchez*
Secretariat: "BoJack."
"When you get sad...you run..."
"straight ahead"
"and..and you keep running forward"
"no matter what."
"There are people in your life
who are gonna try to hold you back"
"slow you down but you don't let them."
"Don't you stop running and don't you ever look behind you."
"There's nothing for you behind you."
"All that exists is what's ahead."
But once he’s disqualified from racing and
can no longer keep the thoughts at bay...
"You can be the fastest runner in the world, but you can't outrun the truth."
The second case is Sarah Lynn.
BoJack drags Sarah Lynn on a months long bender that only ends when she OD’s
on well BoJack
(the heroin, not the horse).
Looking back on it that might have been a bit on the nose.
If trying to reclaim his distracted state
is doomed to end in tragedy
what other options does BoJack have?
Part 2: Radical Freedom
From the beginning, BoJack rejects responsibility:
“I’m responsible for my own happiness?"
"I can’t even be responsible for my own breakfast.”
He wants to escape the realities
of his own terrible life choices.
BoJack: "I didn't do anything wrong because I can't do anything wrong."
"EVERYTHING IS MEANINGLESS!"
"NOTHING I DO HAS CONSEQUENCE!"
After his first bender, BoJack asks Diane:
"Am I just doomed to be the person that I am?"
"The person person in that book?
"I know that I can be selfish and narcissistic
and self destructive"
"but underneath all that, deep down"
"I'm a good person and
I need you to tell me that I'm good."
BoJack is afraid of what 20th Century French
philosopher Jean-Paul Sartre called
“Radical Freedom”
which was a major focus of his philosophy
Existentialism.
BoJack: "I stand by my critique of 'Sartre'."
"His philosophical arguments helped many
tyrannical regimes justify over-cruelty."
"Also the French smell and I hate them."
If Existentialism had a catchphrase, it would be:
“Existence Precedes Essence.”
An object’s essence, for Sartre, can be thought of as its purpose.
If I make a hammer, I create it with a particular purpose in mind
i.e. hammering, so we would say that the hammer’s essence
precedes its existence.
For a Christian a human is like a hammer
a tool created by God with a purpose in mind.
But for an Existential Nihilist, humans, and horsemen
exist just because.
Unlike a hammer or a Gentle Farms chicken
there’s no purpose underlying BoJack’s existence and nothing he is meant to do.
There is nothing stopping BoJack from stealing
the D from the Hollywood sign
or doing three months worth of drugs, and on the flip side
nothing forcing him to do those things either.
BoJack has total control over every choice he makes.
This is what Sartre meant by
“Radical Freedom”
and it's definitely not supposed to be comforting:
“That is what I mean when I say that man
is condemned to be free."
"Condemned, because he did not create himself,"
"yet is nevertheless at liberty,"
"and from the moment that he is thrown into this world"
"he is responsible for EVERYTHING he does.”
Or, as Diane and BoJack put it:
Diane: “That’s the thing, I don’t think I believe in 'deep down'."
"I kinda think all you are is
just the things that you do.”
BoJack: "Well that's depressing."
There is no “good BoJack” deep down.
There is only the one BoJack
and he is entirely defined by the choices
he's made so far.
Or, as Todd puts it to BoJack at the end of season 3:
"You are all the things that are wrong with you."
While this might not seem too comforting it does offer BoJack one bit of hope:
Yes, BoJack is defined by the choices
he's made so far
but he is not “doomed to be the person in that book” forever.
He has the freedom to change his actions and himself.
But it’s entirely up to him to do so.
"It's never too late to be the person you want to be."
"You need to choose the life you want."
The show provides an optimistic take on Sartre
by using water as a metaphor for
BoJack’s Radical Freedom.
BoJack often finds himself
overwhelmed by water.
But at the end of the underwater episode in Season 3
after falling from the ledge of the taffy factory
BoJack finally recognizes the water for what it is
not an overwhelming and scary force
but instead a medium of incredible opportunity.
Part 3: Embrace The Absurd
When Mr. Peanutbutter’s brother gets sick he goes through his own existential crisis:
"Come to work, clock in, you put sugar in your coffee"
"and watch it slowly disappear into nothingness."
"But the sugar doesn’t know why. Sugar didn’t ask to be born."
But he doesn’t suffer
through it for very long.
"I realized something today,
when my brother called from the hospital."
"And I think it's gonna make you feel a lot better."
BoJack: "What? What is it?"
Mr. Peanutbutter: "None of this matters!"
BoJack gets similar advice from his
old writing partner and Harvard alum Cuddly Whiskers
who abandoned his Hollywoo life
Cuddly: "An Oscar is meaningless. It's all meaningless."
and is finally able to find happiness.
"Only after you give up everything can you begin to find a way to be happy."
Mr. Peanutbutter’s and Cuddly Whisker’s
paths to happiness after
or even because of the realization of nihilism
invokes the 20th century French thinker Albert Camus
and his philosophy of Absurdism.
For Camus, the universe is irrational and meaningless
and yet humans are desperate to find
reason and meaning in it.
And he called this discrepancy “The Absurd”.
Once you become aware of “The Absurd”, you only have three choices:
Return to the cycle of daily life and don’t think about it, commit suicide,
or, his preferred option rebellion
i.e., accept the absurd and be happy anyway,
because screw the universe
for thinking it can control how you feel.
Camus illustrates these ideas in his essay ,The Myth of Sisyphus,
about a man who is doomed to push a rock up a hill each day
only to watch it roll back down again.
Sisyphus becomes Camus’s "Absurd Hero"
when he recognizes the absurdity of his task
but decides to be happy in spite of it.
The show directly references The Myth of Sisyphus.
Princess Carolyn: "I have to push a boulder up a hill"
"and then have it roll over me time and time again"
There’s also a recurring symbol of the Baboon
jogging up the hill outside BoJack’s house.
Every day, he’s running up that same hill.
"It get's easier."
BoJack: "Huh?"
Baboon: "Everyday it gets a little easier."
Bojack: "Yeah?"
Baboon: "Butcha gotta do it everyday."
"That's the hard part."
At the end of Season Three
BoJack comes face to face
with the meaningless loop of his life
in the young actress from “Ethan Around”.
Sarah: "I wanna be like you."
BoJack: "Like me?"
Sarah: "I wanna be famous."
BoJack: "Oh no."
“It happens that the stage set collapses..."
"At the end of the awakening comes,
in time, the consequence: "
"Suicide or recovery.”
Just as Camus describes BoJack runs out of the stage set
and begins to drive into nowhere.
Driving has repeatedly served as a way for
BoJack to try to escape the absurd
maybe his own take on Secretariat's advice to
“run and don’t look back.”
But when he releases the steering wheel
BoJack gives in submitting himself to the Absurd and to suicide.
However, when he sees the Wild Horses
they represent for him the alternative:
Embrace the absurd carry out your meaningless task
and be happy in spite of it.
They may be seen as absurd heroes a group of horses,
a group of horses who have embraced running
purely for its own sake.
Like Sisyphus, they run carry out the meaningless task and are happy anyway.
BoJack has proven himself willing to give everything up.
Maybe he is ready to follow Cuddly Whisker’s advice
and can finally start to become happy.
Conclusion
The show does offer one possible solution
to BoJack’s struggle for meaning:
Family.
BoJack: "At our age, it's weird if you don't have a family."
"I mean..."
Charlotte: "Well...not for you."
Bojack: "No."
Charlotte: " 'Cause you've been busy..."
BoJack: "Right"
Charlotte: "...with your career."
BoJack: "Sure."
When you pay attention to the all the times
BoJack watches “Horsin Around”
the scenes all revolve around the in-show family.
BoJack as "The horse": "I've learned that when you're in a loving family"
"there's nothing wrong with a little"
"horsin' around."
*get it?....it's the name of the show*
During the first big bender
he has a vision of himself as a simple family man.
BoJack’s attempt to sleep with Penny
at the end of Season 2
illustrates how desperate he is to start over
and choose the domestic life
he could have had with Charlotte.
The Wild Horses may represent more
than just the "Absurd Hero"
they may also represent the herd
and a sense of belonging that BoJack lacks.
And with the teaser at the end of season three
it seems the show is preparing to explore
this theme of family much more.
Though I hope it works out for him
something tells me that even family
won’t be able to fill the void.
Hey Guys!
As always thanks for watching.
Real quick.
If you're looking for another cool channel that explores your favorite
movies, tv shows, and video games
Then go check out
Looper
From fun movie lists
to hidden easter eggs
Looper releases addictive new videos
everyday of the week
Click here to visit their channel page
and Subscribe.
And if you got cartoons on the mind
go check out their video on the
"untold truth of South Park".
So go subscribe to Looper
and tell 'em Wisecrack sent you.
And finally, if you're interested in another cartoon
about the ramifications of a godless universe
Click on this plumbus to check out our video on
The Philosophy of Rick and Morty
WUBBA LUBBA DUB DUUUUB!
Alright, enough for me.
I've got another Purge video to work on.
Thanks a lot guys.
Peace